he gives up his Queen Magnus C and
surely Fabiana is going to take it but
look at the white Pawn the remaining
white Pawn is so far Advanced still not
over yet Magnus has lost his Queen but
he's still fighting he's fighting
because it's all relying on these two
pawns moving ahead and faban run on
seconds and he can watch this with Just
4 seconds on the Block I think he made
those quick moves to gain the incr and
reminder to everybody 3 seconds added
every single move you make so a quick
check go block that pawn and then push
your own pawns Fabby can win this game
even if he loses Queen for those two
pawns then he can push the Pawns of his
own a rook can stop but he give Che wow
he just blundered the pawn with Czech he
should have pushed the other one the G
Pawn wrong choice there and Magnus is
alive look at those white Pawns in the
black queen and this can be scary for
black because now the queen can't move
anywhere with the check without allowing
the dwn to promote Magnus is does he
have enough to hold this will'll be
captured both sides they're struggling a
bit here five doesn't know where to go
but now ready for M he brings his Rook
all the way downit he chooses the wrong
Square he trapped his own Queen and it's
from Magnus Carson does the unbelievable
he wins down a queen